sous cette enseigne créée en 1974 39
salariés dont cinq dans ce magasin de
fort de france
ici l'on se dit prêt à mettre en oeuvre
le prélèvement à la source en janvier le
trésor public communiqué le taux
d'imposition de chaque employé
cela ne sera pas sans mal mais la
gérante y croit ça a été un gros travail
effectivement surtout pour nous les
petites entreprises
c'était compliqué parce qu'un interne
nos comptables déjà ont dû aller en
formation travail et lui qu'on fasse
appel à notre à nos sociétés qui gèrent
nos logiciels de paye qui a été modifié
plusieurs fois cette année donc ça nous
a pris beaucoup de temps et ça nous a
coûté de l'argent aussi
et aujourd'hui quel état d'esprit
êtes-vous par rapport à cette première
échéance qui arrive
bon on va pas dire serein se seraient
pas bien mais on va voir
j'ai envie de dire je t'ai pas on est au
pied du mur et on verra en effet l'étape
dfid de la réforme mais le casse tête
est transféré sur les entreprises
celles ci doivent bouleverser leurs
méthodes de paye et le cas échéant gérer
inquiétude et mécontentement du
personnel au magasin une réunion
d'information est programmée pour la
semaine prochaine
on s'est vraiment pas du tout comment ça
va se passer au calme en tant qu on
apprenne avait sur nos fiches de
salaires donc à partir du mois prochain
on verra vraiment où on en est j'ai déjà
mis de côté parce qu'on ne sait pas à
quelle sauce on sera mangé donc du coup
on verra ce que ça va donner
vous êtes un petit peu inquiète on
dirait un petit peu quand même parce que
c'est pas toujours évident du coup quand
on a un enfant à charge et où il ya trop
appuyé dans ce magasin de téléphonie
l'on s'estime un peu abandonnés par les
autorités
la direction voudrait bien être prête
pour janvier mais voilà les tours de
nombreux collaborateurs n'ont pas été
transmis absolument pas encore on entend
dire qu'on va recevoir les toucs de nos
salariés mais on les a pas encore ça
n'est pas disponible sur internet
non jusqu'à hier connexion rien donc on
attend
j'espère quand même que ça va arriver
suffisamment tôt qu'on puisse organiser
quoi ça vous met quand même j'imagine un
petit peu en panique où on essaye de ne
pas stresser mais oui forcément on se
pose des questions pour ou contre la
réforme
les avis personnel sont divers mais la
mise en oeuvre elle est tout autre chose
et chaque salarié devra repenser
entièrement sa façon de gérer son budget
oui tout à fait je payais mais
personnellement je paye mes impôts
annuellement donc de devoir mon budget
mensuel diminué et qu'on ne me laisse
pas le choix au niveau de ma façon de
gérer mes finances je ne cache pas que
je le range l'heure je le ressens un
petit peu négativement
il y a aussi la confiance envers le
système yat-il erreur comment la
corriger et quand les trésors publics
rendra-t-il les réductions d'impôts
auxquels certains endroits dans ce
domaine 2010neuf s'annonce comme l'année
de toutes les questions